internet à haute vitesse pour le québec
le canada pour tout le monde même dans
les régions les plus éloignées
c'est un besoin reconnu comme
essentielle nous lançons un plan
d'infrastructures de 10 milliards de
dollars permettra d'investir dans
plusieurs secteurs incluant l'internet
haute vitesse est un grenier pourquoi
pas internet haute vitesse pour tout le
monde surtout ta planète grâce à une
constellation de satellites à basse
altitude le grand rêve en fait c'est
qu'un jour tout le monde ait accès à
l'internet est évidemment la pandémie a
peut-être accentuer ce besoin alors dont
il est à la recherche de solutions sans
nipple actuellement quatre compagnies ou
un projet de constellation de satellites
à basse altitude
léo comme lower aux bêtes l'une d'entre
elles est canadienne télésat cette
constellation contrat 280 18 satellites
tournant autour de la planète
un mille kilomètres d'altitude very à 78
satellites en orbite polaire au dessus
de régions moins peuplées et 220 en
orbite inclinée pour couvrir le reste de
la planète
télésat promet une connexion internet
aussi bonne que la plus haute vitesse
terrestre à la concurrence sera féroce
les sexes d'elon musk a déjà lancé plus
de 800 satellites en basse orbite avec
sa fusée réutilisables falcon 9 et
prévoit en lancé par étapes jusqu'à 40
2000 un projet appelé starlink déjà on
essaie par l'armée de l'air américaine
[Musique]
wan web a déjà mis en orbite six
satellites sur un total de 650 mhz et le
financement pourrait être problématique
ce sera moins un problème pour le
multimilliardaire jeff bezos d'amazon
pour son projet carpe 3236 satellites
autour de la terre mais il est en retard
sur ces deux compétiteurs américains
le projet leo de telesat sera plus
modeste moins coûteux 3 milliards de
dollars possiblement certainement avec
l'aide des gouvernements et l'argent qui
sera récupérée en cédant sa part du
spectre de trois mille 800 mégahertz au
gouvernement fédéral qui doit le mettre
aux enchères l'an prochain on en a
besoin pour la 5g notre oscillations
comme tel et un peu plus en france et
qu'un nouveau compétiteur entre chaque
samedi les autres différences
importantes selon le pdg
télésat ne cherche pas comme les
concurrents à servir directement le
consommateur mais ses clients habituels
sur une des
bin hammam avec une longue expérience 50
ans télésat opère plus d'une douzaine de
satellites géostationnaires pour des
gouvernements des télécoms des
compagnies aéronautiques ou de
navigation avec des satellites leo en
basse orbite leur connexion sera
meilleure et le routage et demain c'est
que ça étant la couverture du la
collection ou la connectivité internet à
l'ensemble de la période que les
opérateurs cellulaires perez pourront
jamais faire et surtout pas dans le
domaine maritime donc deux places fait
maritime est assez importante échéance
décision sur une entrée en bourse pour
le capital et choix du constructeur de
satellites avant la fin de l'année gros
contrats d emploi ne vibre pas rassuré m
cobac ensuite choix du lanceur les fusée
falcon 9 de spacek sont opérationnels
celle du patron d'amazon blue origin ne
le sont pas encore mais elle pourrait
lancer deux fois plus de satellites d'un
coût une trentaine il faudra le financer
ce sera facile pour personne mais le jeu
en vaut la chandelle
l'espace ses enfants aujourd'hui la
dernière frontière permettait d'être un
peu philosophe sur sur ce sujet c'est
littéralement un espace qui reste encore
à coloniser direct les puissances
spatiales qu'il faut partie du club
sélect de l'espace dont le canada fait
partie
toujours à la recherche de nouvelles
applications ou maintenir une présence
dans l'espace
cette nouvelle conquête de l'espace
commence trois américains contre un
canadien la lutte sera chaude
il n'y a pas de place pour tous
[Musique]